when you made the transition you said it
you're ten you that's when you started
being yourself more on stage
and that's when i changed my style i was
like myself i just was saying
yeah i just changed what i was going to
be talking about i didn't want to talk
about nothing that
somebody generally was going to i was
going to do a lot more research a lot
more studying and going
depth on [ __ ] and find the most gruesome
[ __ ] to make funny
and saying it even even stuff that was
inside me hey you ain't you ain't you
haven't been telling these stories
people don't realize people don't
realize this at all
i hadn't told a prison story until i did
this is not happening
whoa and you've had multiple albums
before that
that's that's wow i hadn't i
hadn't told that one prison story what
was that consciously or you just said
that was very conscious i didn't want
people to think i was some one
trick oh ollie do whatever like nah
right
i'm not the prison comic so it took me
16 years i was going to stand up for 16
years before i
ever remember i did in 08 i did death
jam i was a season finale on death jam
i was on common view 2001 to 2004.
i was on off the chain i was on bill
believers who got jokes
i was on a lot of stuff before i did
this is not happening
and you had the vision to know i don't
want to be that so i'm saving that
and i just not even thought i was going
to ever even do it it was just
it's like i told stories to my friends
so they were like man
one of these days man you gotta say that
on stage and i never
he's like bill told me to say a bunch of
stuff
and then the the thing comes when
a person who is your mentor says hey man
you wanna be you want me to be real with
you
the funny how funny you gonna be
is determined on how honest you gonna be
i mean that's when that's when you're
gonna be different when you decide that
you
have whatever honesty and whatever truth
you want to say
that's when you're gonna start being
[ __ ] hysterical
and that was dl higgly
just like when when cheryl underwood
told me
which sometimes she [ __ ] forget that
she told me this because she
act like she had forgetting she even
know me or some [ __ ]
but on the tom join the cruise i'll
never forget it and
and this is the crazy thing [ __ ] like
she don't [ __ ] know me but i said i
say this story and
very in [ __ ] the detail is that
i can say it
because it is going to be nothing but
straight detail
she was coming out of the spa on the
cruise she had on this [ __ ] long
floyd thing that was like blue and green
with a little splash of red but it was
white based this [ __ ]
flip big flip hat on and
we talking and she said i had dress at
the time
she said ali i'll tell you something
you want to be successful in common you
gotta remember these two things
every man gotta wanna be
you and every [ __ ] gotta wanna [ __ ]
you that's serious
and and i and i thought about what she
said
and it's the truth
to be successful and stand up
every man gotta want to be you
it won't be funny
every woman god wanna [ __ ] you
85 percent of any comedy club made up of
women
if you are not attractive
no and i'm talking about one thing is
you ask any woman
it's just a psychology [ __ ] when you go
deeper into it when you ask any woman
name your top three things you want your
man to be
i guarantee you [ __ ] funny come
up
make me laugh come up i guarantee cause
funny is sexy
that transcends you pass what's your
physical [ __ ] look like
shane she was right and so i cut my hair
i um i tailored up i was already
dressing with
taylor's suits and [ __ ] but i tailored
up more
i i switched my style up a lot
and i combined with d.l and cheryl said
together there's other there's other
people
out there as well but like dick gregory
and
dez white and rob stapleton there's a
lot of other people who
who gave me solid ass advice
so when i get ready to write a book
which would be soon here
um awesome it'll be a book of
quotes i think
the story i'ma lay the story out of how
i got the quote
like it's gonna be the quote then it's
gonna be the story
behind the quote and then i wanna get
the person who who told me the quote to
sign
in the book
[Music]